ein wundervoller morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meinen ich war es in der letzten
folge mannschaft mit luca haben wir auf
dem rückweg unserer gassi tour von
dahinten hier vorne irgendwo genau hier
ein ozean monument gefunden und da habe
ich euch zum ende der letzten folge
gefragt was muss ich beachten denn ich
will der heute reingehen und alle haben
mir geschrieben jeder nicht rein
du wirst instant sterben ich muss mir
wohl noch einen trank machen da würde
ich die status effekte nicht bekomme ich
solle mir noch unter wasser atmen
verzaubern ich soll mir ich habe keine
ahnung wie wurden so viele sachen
geschrieben
ich entdecke ich im leben während setzen
erst mal was haben wir denn hier alles
in der kiste drehen also ihr habt ihr
schon gerade mitbekommen ich werde jetzt
erstmal so ein bisschen noch das
piratenschiff auseinandernehmen und mir
vor allem hier vorne noch das
lapislazuli mitnehmen diese steinen
druckplatte brauche ich nicht schneller
oben vorher noch ertrinke schnell nach
oben ausbauen also ihr habt mir alle die
kommentare geschrieben lueg ag nicht in
das ocr monument bitte bitte bitte tu
dir selber den gefallen die nach hause
rüstet sich ausgeht in folge reihen von
daher verschieben wir das ganze auch
später wenn wir irgendwann heute den weg
nach hause gefunden haben sollten dann
werde ich das auf jeden fall auch auf
schwarze brett draufschreiben ich habe
ich jetzt auch mal hier runter bauen wir
haben ja von da vorne gesehen dass ich
hier noch eine zweite kiste befindet
beziehungsweise dementsprechend eine
dritte kiss schnell wieder nach oben
auch noch mal kurz ufo kartoffel
zwischen die riemen gehauen und ich
würde dann erst mal sagen dass wir
dieses sehr monument hierbei seite
liegen lassen und uns zunächst erstmal
auf den schatz konzentrieren
ich glaube
sein von daher fahren wir zu der
inselgruppe dort erst mal hin nicht
optimal generell diese korallenriffe
alter ich finde das so geil und ich
freue mich so darauf werden wir bei
unserer bahnstrecke dann irgendwann mal
den tunnel bauen werden ich weiß wenn
jetzt jemand neues bei diesem projekt da
wird sich erst mal denken hey wie viele
projekte hast du denn in deinem projekt
ich weiß wir müssen auf jeden okay wir
haben auf jeden fall ganz ganz viele
sachen zu tun nicht nur in unserem
generellen ganzen projekt hier sondern
auch in der heutigen folge da wir
nämlich nicht in das monument gehen habe
ich mir etwas anderes überlegt denn ich
habe hier ist der schatz ich finde ich
mal eben ganz kurz
[Musik]
und da da da man endlich gefunden weil
der lieben freunde das waren jetzt auch
nur entspannte sieben minuten die ich
hier gebraucht habe also die ganzen
eisenbahn reingesteckt das zehnte hab
ich ja gar kein platz mehr
und wenn er nicht den ganzen sachen habe
ich ja schon eingesteckt dem euch auf
jeden fall für den eigentlich wollte ich
den part den ihr hier jetzt gerade in
der time letzte rausschneiden da jedoch
in letzter zeit vermehrt kommentare
kommen in die richtung luca chattet guck
mal hier ist nacht und dann im nächsten
karte ist wieder tag an euch ganz kurze
die info ist einfach langweilig wenn ich
das hier drinnen lassen würde ich habe
einfach gewartet bis spinnen spawnen so
dass ich sie bekomme mit der seide wolle
machen kann und mit der rolle mehr im
bett kräften kann um die nacht zu
überspringen also das kurz zur erklärung
und jetzt geht es weiter am nächsten tag
und ich sind mit blumen brötchen ich
habe übrigens immer noch dieses böse
omen hier drin also das nächste dorf was
ich besuche da wird definitiv wieder ein
überfall stattfinden
wir fahren jetzt erst mal ganz kurz da
hinten hin da war ja das schiffswrack
und beziehungsweise kamen wir von da an
war das urteil monument und dann da also
fahren einfach mal hier lagen so ein
bisschen finde ich und weil du was sagst
du ja immer wieder spaß ich mit dir so
ein rot für guckt euch mal an wie schön
dass mit diesen korallenriffen ja
aussieht alter das ist ja der abzug
[Musik]
der heißt das bak bonn
heute und dahin ist direkt das nächste
break noch ein schiffswrack
also ich weiß nicht und da bin ich mir
wirklich wirklich sicher ob das alles
[Musik]
hier so circa war das schiff frack und
das odds im moment und ich dachte gerade
bei wir haben hier noch sollten dinge
gefunden hier vorne was ich noch mal
ganz groß sie die tintenfische eben mit
die muss ich mich töten für das glas für
unsere strandvilla benötigen wir nämlich
die in sex die ich hier vorne werde ich
auch einmal ganz kurz mitnehmen da
möchte ich mich ganz viel schwarz
getönte glasscheiben drin haben
ich will auf jeden fall so wie ihr haupt
genommen den kommentaren ich sehe schon
kommen hier voll mich immer kurz töten
weil ich einfach dachte dass wir voll
weit weg sind bei dem ozean monument
aber es war direkt nebenan
ach du scheiße sagt nur kurz haben wir
schon mal 96 und here for less noch ton
den bauten sogar auch noch denn der
einzige grund warum eigentlich auf die
gassen gegangen sind war weil ich die
büsche brauchte für meine ja mal der
strandvilla und für mein haus und da wir
jetzt bekommen haben brauche ich
dementsprechend auch noch blumentöpfe
ich las die
schaufel einfach mal nicht ob das das
unwichtigste von dem ganzen sachen die
ich mit habe dass ich mir zumindest den
ton noch mitnehmen kann man alter ich
dachte wir haben hier neues fischer als
piraten boden entdeckt aber dann ist es
einfach das boot was wir schon vor 20
folgen entdeckt haben alle leute die neu
mit dabei sind dieses boot da hinten war
das erste piratenschiffs fragt was ich
entdeckt habe und hier vorne ist ja
meine insel beziehungsweise erstmal die
willicher insel war wie schön das hier
alles außer der da freut man sich
wirklich wieder zu hause anzukommen und
ihr werdet bereits auch schon im titel
eingeblendet das ist jetzt gar nicht war
ein überfall findet statt auf meiner
seite jetzt kommen die römer hier auf
meine inseln stehende augen auf beim das
kann sich auch wieder nicht ausdenken
schreiben ja noch nicht wie das alles
ist
[Musik]
das zitat die situation ich stehe und
der hier
da geht richtig ab
der big mac
sind viele bäume gefällt worden was ist
denn los nur wegen diesen überfall jetzt
ist meine halbe insel kaputt sagt tack
tuut tuut tuut tuut tuut tuut und jetzt
hier der letzte so jetzt haben wir es
dass das ist nicht euer ernst de was ist
los man ich muss im sicherheit was geht
hier ab heute diese ganzen geräusche
guckt euch mal
ich kann jetzt in die schmiede diese
geister drin negativ linie überall rum
wie soll ich das denn schaffen ohne juli
oder so weiß nicht dass gerade eine big
brain 5000 idee von mir ist
aber ich bleibe einfach hier oben und
die versammeln sich unter mir und ich
schieße die vorher einfach ab
jetzt geht's los getan
eine grüne 9 %
der inselstaat ist so wenn man im dorf
geht oder warum habe ich ein totem der
unsterblichkeit wenn der überfall noch
immer läuft kriegt man das nicht am ende
ich werde jetzt so in den krieg gehen
die armbrust geladen auf den skis ich
das ding wo hier rein einfach zack da
muss weg ich werde jetzt auch ganz viel
mit pfeilen arbeiten oder einfach da
rein schießen
aber wir kriegen das hin freunde wie
kriegen das sind das können haben sind
auch eine komische beschreibt warum habe
ich oben rechts ein herz generation habe
ich 14
ach so die hexe verzaubert die angreifer
hier mit positiven effekten und mich mit
negativen aber ich habe gerade glaube
ich irgendwie einen positiven effekt
abgestaubt ich werde mich jetzt auch
generell erst mal auf die hexen
konzentrieren damit die deren leute
nicht irgendwie mal wieder heilen können
und er brachte eine ganze insel kaputt
was soll dass man den leuten draußen weg
birgt weg was ihr gar nichts ich kann
euch mal ganz kurz sagen was ich
eigentlich heute machen wollte und ich
habe ja auch schon zu beginn der folge
gesagt dass das im titel steht und zwar
wollte ich eine riesige geile bessere
portal insel bauen weil ich finde dass
montag kommen jetzt will ich der mega
egal was passiert sagte hängt irgendwie
fest ok irgendwas das heißt wir können
auf jeden fall töten er ist tot
ich wollte eigentlich in der heutigen
folge diese portal insel abbauen und
hier hinstellen und zwar in richtig
riesig da habe ich mir richtig viele
gedanken gemacht das wird richtig nein
das passiert jetzt nichts mit dir schöne
alle für die herzliche art und schwere
tier jetzt super weil machen alter des
toten wurde vorne
schlägt er zurück war die ganze saison
als super nun der reihenhaus ab er ist
tot
wir haben nur noch zwei und das einmal
handy mit der hässlichen nasenbär axt
der tod noch zwei räuber stehen auch
meine lieben freunde das ist für einen
kennst du das täglich nation wo bist du
ich getötet
modell der vorgestellten müsste
eigentlich der letzte sein euro kostet
diese komischen teile daher schnell
wieder ein
alexander rath
der gab das ganze
red
sehr gut ich meine das nicht
cook den platz gegangen
26 erfahrungs level sind weg eine ganze
insel ist warum alles sieht es aus ich
wollte einfach nur die sind immer noch
da
ich wollte einfach nur auf add ins
dingsbums jagd gehen wollte ich auf
erkundungstour ich wollte balu gassi
gehen
ich hab sie mir es ist jetzt alles
scheißegal
h
[Musik]
das becken ist kannst du dir nicht
ausdenken
ich folge hat so schön gestartet ich
habe mein zuhause wieder gefunden ich
habe alles hier wieder gefunden
[Musik]
und ich hatte nur dieses totem der
unsterblichkeit in der hand aber ich
wusste nicht wie es rein setzte das war
keine gute folge heute
jetzt geht auch noch die sonne unter
meine lieben freunde wenn euch die
heutige folge vielleicht dennoch
gefallen hat oder ihr zumindest mitleids
daumen da lassen wollt dann lasst den
daumen hoch jetzt unter dem video da
sehe ich auch so
[Musik]